yeah let's bring out Blake Griffin is
here and Andrew Schultz let's bring
those two guys out Andrew Santino you
can add your salt walked into walk-in
yeah all three of them just come out
together Oh where's that fashion song
fashion fashion Andrew Santino as well
Andrew Schulz
Blake Griffin is here
Blake is the taller of the pair
yeah just in case there's any confusion
everybody we're being in front of an
audience in the morning isn't it yeah
yeah I couldn't believe that people were
gonna be not you know just start out but
I didn't even understand what was going
on I know it's a panel it's a panel
discussion so is this are we going live
on Sirius as waste is our morning show
oh yeah guys yeah this is the show that
we do in the morning I mean you know
you're my favorite I don't and I have a
show with a radio guy right and still
well I appreciate that
and Blake Griffin you seem a little more
comfortable being here than Andrew shelf
does yeah
you understand doing press in the
morning that's when shows are on yeah
it's kind of hard it's good that you
guys didn't spread out over two couches
I wish it your mustache so do we look so
much alike and a lot of people were like
like material your your comedies gotten
so offensive and I was like the Schulz
I'm not don't do I had a horrible
horrible yet Mateo Lane mustache that I
was trying to it was really bad I mean
that's not that complimentary to Mateo
is well no cuz his is like thick and
Italian I was like go on the most
Scottish
it's a breaking bad mustache like John
Waters penciled it in I believe the
Bryan Cranston once described it as like
impish was that the word to use the
impish must've might look like bean
sprouts
you were hot you were holding on to it
man I was trying so hard yet the cell
you're like I'm keeping it ladies love
it I'm keeping it yeah ladies or is that
something you were just kind of telling
yourself okay I kept telling myself
right and then it was more guys yeah so
I so Blake how long you been doing
stamps I met you like two years ago I
think you were your hoster to show up
here out so I met you
yeah three years ago I did I hosted
midnight surprise show three years ago
it was yeah yeah no I remember you were
walking around and everyone was losing
their mind and I'm like so no offense I
was like who is this and then and I
walked up to you I was like I need a
photo my straight friends would love if
I got a photo I had no idea what's for
the nothing yeah they were like how the
[ __ ] did you he was walking around and
taking pictures of everybody yeah so I
started maybe like four years ago I did
some stuff in LA then did some stuff
here and then have kind of just done
random stuff here and there and but you
must love it though because you make you
make money you know doing what you do
for a living you don't need this so you
playing basketball
I mean there's so much money there you
do make money playing basketball right
like this hopefully it's enough to tide
you over in the awesome okay good take
this water and hitching every penny you
must just love doing stand-up I just
love stand-up in general I try not to
like go do like a show and like take
somebody's spot so I like hosting stuff
my charity events here so I get a chance
to like bring up you know five
communities who I really like well
you've won every comedian over already
you don't take our spots and give us
spots yeah yeah you're in that's all I
would do if I was really famous is take
people's spot
I'd walk in Jersey on I'm going on next
okay what is Bobby on did you have to
figure that out like that that was the
way to handle this like did you have to
figure out the comedy community once you
started getting in or did you realize
that's kind of the way all these you
know kind of inside communities work I
mean I I just got I would hate for a
comedian to come take some please
following my team right just wait I'll
call I just kind of like that's just
that was kind of my approach from the
beginning I didn't really have to like
get into that after a fight with a
comedian I had a nightmare last night
it's funny you said I had a dream last
night that a girl came to see me at the
Comedy Cellar that's it no and Chapelle
bumped me that was just my dream that I
was trying to like be you know that I
was doing something in Dave Chappelle
came in and bumped me it was humiliating
see what I that's means life is pretty
good if that's your worst nightmare but
repellant on first my first when I like
auditioned for the cellar the first time
I got bumped by Chappelle on Friday and
then rock on Saturday so did you not get
to audition I did like maybe the
following week but like I remember
wracking you know week of my life
and finally Friday comes around like all
right [ __ ] it I'm ready to go and then
spell comes anyway I mean that's a
pretty cool thing I said I'll do it
tomorrow that rock comes and I was like
Jesus two weeks of sustained did you
complain to the management I went right
to s T I had a scheduled I didn't have
any stock in this other one I audition
it was weird like this guy Rick Dorfman
was my manager at the time and he got me
into Dangerfield's and the seller the
same day and he's like you have an
audition at there's like 95 or 96 and it
was it was less pressure then then there
is now ended all of it because I mean
this all has always been the seller but
like when did it become it wasn't always
like that it was you beat it was one
long show and you would have a lot of
times we want to do food spots at night
like the late-night spots were all for
food right and they were 10-minute spots
and there's six people on a Monday
sometimes it was empty
oh it's empty a lot Colin going in there
really
the lock is important like Seinfeld and
other guys back in yeah was that one the
turnaround was I think so yeah Colin had
a lot to do with that which I hate to
say I have a question do you G is this
story true old cellar story I think
you're you're there for our team at the
one I just told I'm like lady I would
make up a better story than that like
really sometimes on a Monday six people
great job what a [ __ ] story that would
be to make up your sometimes in this
story but I'm not sure if it's true like
you know you hear like these back tables
sure and it's a story about there's a
comic from like Ohio this was like back
in the day
he was bringing his his CD at the time
to audition right and he just he just
kind of showed up went to the back table
you're there Patrice is there a few
other guys are there and he goes hey
guys do you think you could give this to
the owner of the club and then Patrice
goes yeah sure let me see it okay
take the CD snap don't remember it and
that doesn't sound like anything Patrice
with you I've actually never heard that
but if I was there I don't remember but
it's very possible isn't it amazing that
there are so many stories like that that
Jim is saying it's possible that I
forgot it like there's so I might have
forgotten that story ever happened yeah
I'm more remember showing Patrice my
erection in a brothel in Rio de Janeiro
service is that a true story yeah
100 milligrams sigh Alice rod would have
you think you know we giggled it was
true I we had robes on and you wore
robes in the brothel and it was just it
was like 2003 and I had a [ __ ]
hundred milligram viagra Harlan under my
world we're sipping Diet Coke I just
looked down on my dick tenting out and
we just giggled like children like what
are we doing here what a third-world
country just [ __ ] girls for $50
hundred milligrams is a lot then yeah
yeah me and Keith were doing honey
milligrams and I it was crazy
God see you guys need story you young
comics need stories like these guys you
don't have any brothel hundred milligram
laughter yeah do you like sitting at the
table when it's Keith in you and Bobby
and rich like it does you do get that
feeling of life yes yeah it's more you
got to be on your toes yeah I mean I
hear like young calm except we're
probably like the generation below you
guys talking and they're like oh yeah I
know I know you're not like oh I just
got enough followers that people can
swipe up on my Instagram and I'm like
what happened to the erections in Rio de
Janeiro wipe this conversations now that
the seller are being literally arguing
over how many delta points you have oh
my being like oh my god who's like me
and Jared Freder like I'm almost Diamond
is interesting you know here on back oh
I bet for him to come out - yeah yeah
bring interesting that you know not to
join us and you can sit with us and uh
if he's back there he's a podcast called
whiskey ginger so I'm sorry I be
courting in here there's Andrew
Oh
santino sorry I wasn't happy they didn't
tell me to go out that dude where is he
you know where you are he said don't go
yet
who said that yes you do Roland you
that's right you wrote don't go yet he's
also said that in cancer wards very
dramatic now Blake not that the
gentleman that we're here worth aren't
also high-profile but do you worry when
you go up on stage to even just you know
open a show do five minutes whatever it
is do you have that realization that
like okay because I'm a professional
athlete and I'm a high profile person
whatever I say if it's anything
controversial people are gonna want to
make a story out of it yeah absolutely
I'm pretty somewhat careful a little bit
like Schultz I try me I obviously try
out to get myself in trouble but you
know I guess the more and more I do it
the more I push the envelope here and
there yeah
because it seems like a good time you
start pushing the head blow yeah yeah
it's a lot easier than it's ever been
you what you are doing the anti-semetic
show at midnight sally do stand up to
you should play for the Pistons I heard
he did stand up I don't know who Sally
Sally
yeah really thing about playing bass I'd
like to see him with a hundred milligram
viagra people exclusively ask you
questions about other basketball yeah
it's the same as comedy too
I don't really know John Salley to be
honest yeah I hear Kareem likes Donuts
[Laughter]
old school plot might even ask you but
anybody relevant no do you want it I
like when you perform now are you
looking at this like okay once I'm done
being an athlete this is something that
I want to get into full-time I don't
know
about getting into a full-time but is
something I love I loved watching since
I was a kid and been a fan I click over
the Comedy Store in LA and just sit and
watch who are some of your favorite
comics growing up and then now growing
up like I would watch like Pryor Murphy
I was I got older Rock Chapelle have you
bombed yet like I mean really bombed
yeah like real real I skipped a step of
like having to go up and like make a
name for myself in a way just because
every time I do it I feel like most
people what it's not a guarantee of
everybody so every time I go up I'm like
this could be it yeah but it's okay when
it happens you'll survive it it won't be
a big deal but Blake Griffin is smart
because the old Seinfeld quote is that
when you're famous you get a five-minute
buffer that's and then after that you
have to actually perform be funny so
Blake goes how about I go up and do five
minutes that was for 55 on the nose I
was looking for backstage I was like
Peter sneak and peek I couldn't tell
when I saw your legs nose Burgas I I
thought that was Mateos leg stammers bro
I didn't know yeah notoriously long toes
[ __ ] I should be opening a door with
those Velociraptor where this guy's
[ __ ] skis on it what do you Blake what
do you 16 i 6 1899
[Laughter]
so what is your what is your pocket I
was watching some of it and we are used
to interview people loser yeah we have
usually at we usually have a drink but
now everybody's [ __ ] sober so crazy
like it started with me having a drink
with friends and talking [ __ ] and then
so many people came out like Bobby Lee
comes on all the time and Bobby's sober
now more and more people like I'm doing
to hear Black Thought is coming on and
black thought is like this black not
from the roots okay yeah and he was
sober too so I was once a week that was
complaining that he was like taking his
pants off on stage mm-hmm but no [ __ ]
she was like why didn't really see his
penis so I'm not gonna like file a
formal complaint because he does the
notorious they have a small penis it
hides behind his pubes so when he shows
that sometimes you don't know if it's
element or pubes does he have or how
small is his penis it's got it's a
duality it's a magic eye if you get
close to them it was your sunflower face
looks surrounded by the little uh
it's like that little baby in the Sun on
the yeah that's nothing to comics now I
mean talking about like back in the day
everyone I feel like so many people are
sober now you can sit at the table at
the cellar and everybody's just like oh
no I'm only water like only cause it's a
new wave I might be the only guy that
still drink I don't know do you drink do
you tree
I like every literally make once that
reforming I that makes me so mad no one
does it anymore yeah you drink Schultz
yeah more so knowing walk in the other
way you do you so much yeah now are so
sober now in the game it's really kind
of weird like your generation of guys
got sober yeah and then you guys needed
it I started talking yes I was a sober
young and it's like thank God because
social media I think that Sobers a lot
of people up to and they're like [ __ ]
man there's Twitter that's Instagram
yeah there's all these places to go and
ruin your career with one line right you
didn't have before you know I started
there was you couldn't go out and [ __ ]
your career up with one line from home
yeah that's because you were also an
emotional attention-seeking yes I was I
was a little emo lesbian all comics for
becoming sober and all athletes are
alcoholic there's hope how anybody
performs as an athlete [ __ ] up like I
don't know how guys go through that and
get [ __ ] up and still succeed doing
that well I mean maybe not like wow
while we're playing but I just feel like
they said that Rodman used to do that
though Rodman used to like guys Sam
Perkins I guess I should have said
alcoholic but like most is just drink
you know right a lot yeah you ever have
to drink a lot right your big people
like nice big people
it's not but baseball players they
[ __ ] day drink more than any athlete
I've ever met
like hanging out baseball players some
not name names but like some guys I know
they can party all [ __ ] night and
then go play that's because I take an
average baseball player that's like 98
seconds of actual play time aggressive
athleticism in a day and then they're
done we didn't get to hang out yeah well
David well drink and then they go play
yeah oh yeah do you do you KITT do you
get liquored up and go play the next day
no not me it's [ __ ] PR guys like
David Wells almost threw a perfect game
he was a [ __ ] mess yeah oh the wasn't
perfect and that he was stuck for the
ages for the Yankees better years ago he
didn't look like a drunk no I know
everybody by the way baseball coming
back to Montreal you guys are gonna
share it with water you must be psyched
yeah half a team huh that's fun look
there's not one person everybody's like
I have no idea what you're talking about
yeah it wasn't even disinterest it was
like yeah I heard that guy this guy this
guy you look what is this guy like he
looks like his master energy drink he
was drinking I that was the only sport I
did play when I was little was Macky
I in but I really just like the skating
aspect of it
who's your favorite hockey players
Dorothy Hamill
Nancy Kerrigan after they fight they
should do like a little spin don't you
think wouldn't it wouldn't any proven
once I got to 13 and everyone got really
mean I quit and then went to musicals
and drawing and stuff and how about
people stop being mean to you then no no
they were mean alter oh do they know in
high school
oh yeah cuz I've had a joker Mike my
name is Matteo Lane and no one ever know
you stop playing hockey just went
straight to [ __ ] it's so funny cause
like I was trying to like act straight
but I was working at Michaels and and I
have you know Mike it's I know there's
nothing like I get [ __ ] what can I help
you craft is on your apron was dating a
girl worked at michaels her name is
Francesca and I broke up with her in the
yarn section I did I was like Francesca
to the yarn section please my fledging
almost I was so gay how long did you
date her for like like I think a month I
mean I have no I did you have sex with
her are you out of your mind oh look at
me I buy more like a I'm a gold star gay
which means I never at all no no there's
also one like we're platinum where if
you never see section you didn't even
touch about this like it was in Newsweek
all the levels gayest thing it's a phone
call from your mom I was reading an
article about platinum game are you
Mateo just classic [ __ ] but yeah but then
there's like animals in it because I
don't I don't like that like we gays
will like name body types after animals
in the animal kingdom so like bears Cubs
seok's no and let see why they call it
gay guys
they call him they call him a good sport
I think it makes me mad cause lesbians
don't do that no lesbians like I'm a
Furby you know K's really take it to a
whole other level did you have like a
fake female celebrity crush I was a
cover no I didn't even have the
confidence you know what I mean cuz my
brother's gay and before he came out he
would walk around telling everybody's
like I'll have the biggest crush on
jennifer Love Hewitt yeah it's like it's
just the easiest like nobody's gonna
question so we're getting there maybe
I'm really around well you're putting
pieces together the mustache the leg in
a sundress how you get a deal at
Montreal who's your crush when you were
yeah like a celebrity crush yeah who's
your celebrity crush I remember loving
Arnold Schwarzenegger when I was younger
which is kind of hacked but I remember
also watching commando thinking like I
could help him on his missions needed
like a young gay spy to help him fight
crime but everybody that lifts weights
gay or not has a crush Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah well now I don't
isn't it's all I'm not really I'm not
attracted to him now but yeah it was a
kid I don't know I mean I just I don't
think I had like a celebrity crush as a
kid yeah I mean I probably would have
picked someone hackie like Halle Berry
like she's so pretty that good gays are
like she's too like you guys telling
someone's gay when they're not out of
the closet when they're describing a
woman cuz every guy's like I [ __ ] her
and this and her [ __ ] egg it's like
it's her eyes you know I'm really under
I like I like the face yeah like I like
a pretty face I like Kristy McNichol
growing up that was my crush
is that her name we grew up in a
generation gone by like yeah we say her
and Tatum O'Neal they we call little
darlings with Armand Assante thank god
you're here this what I deal with every
room with just me go you know I'm I'm
mesmerized by her name her spirit she
was kind of tomboyish she was very cute
she was a big actress in the in the said
nobody knows Kristy McNichol come on
guys crazy Meghna Noel's a real name
that's not like can somebody commit
Christiaan me Irish woman listen I
remember remember at Niccolo remember
Kathy Ireland do you remember her sure
sure she was my that was my he I was in
love James thing is that the Ireland
thing really sent me on I like that [ __ ]
the find out that wasn't a real last
name course now piss me off
my father bought me a [ __ ] Kathy
Ireland poster and like a real douchebag
in front of my in front of my sister is
he was like don't wear it out I was like
[ __ ] you found her right Kristy
McNichol
well yeah she hasn't she it we could
choose boy yeah remember my sister and
my buddy she looks like a good
she was tomboy but her and Tatum O'Neal
would the two like the keep teenagers
back then was a who was weird
thank you you had crushes on Tom boys
and Jamie Lee Curtis yeah she does yes
female genital see would you say she
look
shrewd Toshiba dick Jamie Lee knows I'm
a run with this what a lot of people say
both a lot of time appetite but I guess
it's just if I'm guessing big that
rumors start because entreaty that movie
with John Travolta which is something it
started with her
yeah which she's like humping them it's
like okay we get it you have a vagina
what was the movie Travolta they just
bully each other's genitals I don't know
the movie I just know the meme asteroid
where they hump they're humping each
other
ya know yeah now Andrew Schultz yeah
you're too you're this big Just for
Laughs comedy festival yeah a lot of
industry here yeah
you've spent the the better part of a
year declaring yourself as anti industry
it's not very not anti just not
necessary it's done very well for you
yeah how do they react to you here now
that it's like okay he's been successful
going against the industry um I just
told them I wouldn't go unless they did
exactly what I wanted and a lot of money
[Laughter]
yeah did the neck because I saw Patrice
to do the nasty snow like I would watch
videos on YouTube I see Patrice is like
the best to me ever so I was like a
favor
Joan amazing to I saw John matter of
fact last time was up here I saw Joan
and she opened up something with like
Mexicans are ugly and then the line was
you never seen somebody walking up like
a surgery to go make me Consuelo and
then she died
getting plastic surgery I'm part Mexican
too and I did you still love it I love
Joe she's the best but I was like if I
come up if I come up like one is cool to
hang out with comics obviously and then
to like I just want to do the exact
shows that I want to do and and they
were cool enough to let me do the nasty
show and then the the unsafe set show an
inside joke show and then uh and then
yeah and I was like yeah let's do it
let's make it happen
perfect for sure yeah perfect also
carved out your career now to a point
where I think you you you there's almost
like one day and I know you didn't but
it's almost like one day you turned the
whole comedy community or like I'm going
yeah and yeah and we're like okay let's
see what happens then you came back
you're like I succeeded it was one day
though yeah I was up for a show for Vice
and then they said they're like no and I
was like if I don't get this I'm just
going all in on on YouTube yeah and I
did I just was the show some it was like
the show that would fight you know come
after Jesus and marrow remember to use a
masher yeah yeah yeah and the show was
gonna fail I knew it but it was like my
last time where I was like will I get it
and I hated that [ __ ] feeling of
Sharia like yet it's the most vulnerable
stupid feeling the world's like do I
want my whole life to be this don't want
every like pilot season to be am I gonna
get this show I was like [ __ ] I'll
just make my own shows and then people
start watching them and you know comics
were supportive and then I don't
audition by the way I read ugh I refuse
I beginning yeah first of all every role
written for gay people it's just like
you're always like the [ __ ] best
friend so yeah I've literally read
scripts where it's like what's the sitch
and that character but I'm still like no
and I just don't like the idea of like
me working my ass off every night and
succeed like doing nothing work in my
craft and then someone I don't know it's
like alright tell us your name and then
you go action the [ __ ] up you know what
I mean I'd rather you care to act ever
though yeah but I will just uh and I
know this sounds so arrogant but I'll
just figure it out I'll write myself
into something or be putting this I'm
just I can't with the auditions and the
waiting and the that's why I use have a
joke I'm like I don't understood I want
to be an act
and then all of a sudden your managers
like go audition rolls like Zach 19
football player well Zach's can have a
secret to share with everybody so I'm
the same way I admire you for that
because I I'm not as confident as you
but part of me is like yeah [ __ ] I'm not
doing the audition thing I'm gonna
figure it out it's exhausting and it's
depressing my manager I'm gonna point
out he'll go I got an audition I go why
right Oh what it's not gonna happen but
I still do them I know you get a lot of
acting work yeah but I'm very well I
favorite [ __ ] to go out for like they
don't know what to do with the redhead
like redheads this weird you know think
there's never been a script but it's
like a handsome redhead walks in the
room like so every time I go out it's
always like me a black guy a blind kid
I'm always like in that other category
yeah so then I had to kind of do my own
thing enough where they started to go oh
we know where to put him cuz for a long
time it was no [ __ ] like I walked the
Ian Edwards is a great stand-up and Ian
Edwards and I went out for the same role
twice and look almost identical and as I
walked in the room and very Ian Edwards
fashion he goes this is ridiculous this
is so stupid yeah but it took me for a
long time to find out what I wanted to
do so I don't really I don't I don't say
I'm not like these guys I want like not
audition these guys are superstars you
know they don't audition anymore but I
just don't I just AM more particular Bob
but you're an Espeon bro you are
thespian yes you actor like you're good
at acting you probably studied acting
nope never nope oh yeah that's a mask
yeah really yeah no I just I just kept
pretending until they said yes I just
kept flying until they were like oh he's
good and then I was like oh yeah okay
I'm in the top so you had acting
background as well no no dude I went to
Arizona State University
I'm sure I was a journalism dropout I'm
garbage my problem is which I should get
over it's egotistical but it's an
authority problem I just don't like
Authority and so I don't like being out
of control and people trying to tell you
what your worth is I'm like I just I
didn't I never said I wanted to be an
actor so I'm so confused why me doing
comedy led to me having to do all these
auditions that was this little platform
and so it's like well I've never been
traditional anyways I'm one of the few
gays you know 99.9% of the time and I'm
on a show I'm the only gay on the show
I'm the only gay in the room you know
what's weird about being gay besides all
to gauge it it's like no no I thought
about this for acting purposes like okay
when you yeah we know qualify that first
of all because you like when any of us
becomes like a Power Ranger or something
like that that's acceptable right or if
I'm gonna play like a [ __ ] avatar
that's totally fine right but not be a
guy plays a straight dude in a movie
people like how the [ __ ] could do geezer
make out that girl by the way that's the
only example I can think of - but for
real so it's like I really I'm yeah I
feel for you in terms of acting because
whatever for whatever reason we've
barely accepted guys they just gave us a
note I'm sorry they said Blake has to go
because you have an interview at 9:40
well real quick what is it like being a
gay NBA play
do you have to go through rejection
Blake or or or are you guys so trained
to play like a champion that you just
don't you you can't think on a level
that I might fail today no I mean I
guess there's some guys that I admire
some guys would like the most insane
confidence that I think every shots
going on they think they're gonna win
every game that's not yeah our rejection
is losing and everybody across America
talking [ __ ] about you for with one guy
misses a free-throw it's always fun to
watch like like when a relief pitcher
gives up a home run if a guy misses a
free throw that would and the players
always like Pat oh my god happens but
how much do you [ __ ] hate him but
people walk in locker room really kind
of go oh my god he sucks we knew it I
got it I got to say pinky toe Blake
because I Blake give me a real solid we
did a film together for Whitney Cummings
right and and there was a line in the
film where you know we're like wrestling
and then I say it's good and I said one
of the lines I was like you know the
only team that wants you is your legal
team right and the line was kind of flat
yeah and but then you got traded in real
life so it really worked out for me the
front office I was like guys when I was
a kid I did a thing where I I had a coke
and Mean Joe green threw his jersey oh
my god
catch like please visit us when you're
in New York for sure you can see comedy
by Blake tomorrow at 9:30 at the fifth
room at the Place des Arts plastic arts
yeah and it's Blake Griffin 23 on
Twitter but it's good seeing you man
buddy you're great man
shaking hands look at them shorts that's
incredible
okay I'll come over look Andrew
Santino's join in the comedy couch this
is so intimate talk about acting and
being gay you know it's like in comedy
like it's it's so like like to be a gay
man doing comedy is still like not as
prevalent the most problem that's ever
been yeah but then people always get
shocked I'm like yeah name a gay male
comedian Lisa Lampanelli at the level of
Bill burr who's head of special yes yeah
Marriott Mario Cantone is like and he
doesn't get the credit he deserves cuz
he was who Todd glass yeah but he was
he's got a bill burr level like bills
doing like arenas like it I mean I'm
that level and I think to like out has
anyone ever been out and like yeah well
we had that conversation at the cellar
there's some people that we can you know
we were talking about like the gay
community supporting like gay males
instead of like females like so often
the gay community comes out for like
female singers yeah yeah I'm sure like
yeah like a Barbra Streisand or Lady
Gaga or Madonna lies them or lies it
yeah and then it's like when is that
support gonna happen for dudes I think
it's actually happening now I hide that
show yeah RuPaul's Drag yeah that
comedian like you know Joel Kim Booster
Julio Torres Solomon George oh there's a
lot of queer comics are really doing
awesome things to Buki and it's the
first time it's ever really happened so
it's exciting to see like any time like
Joel just got like an NBC show like
that's so exciting because it's like
finally people are recognizing gay
people can do more than you know be like
a [ __ ] best friend at a wedding movie
or something but yeah we're both drag
race which I've does anyone watch that
show here right Monster Energy Drink I
about that he's getting off the bike and
eating it on time a show has been on TV
that's usually when they make movies or
TV shows about gay people were like it's
made for straight people so it's like
serious or dying of AIDS or some sort of
like queer I which I also love but it's
all about fixing straight people's lives
RuPaul's Drag is the first show for gay
queer people by queer people right and
they don't give a [ __ ] of straight
people don't understand it and it's so
it's exposed all these different types
of lives and it's allowed us to like
appreciate gay men in a way that we
haven't before and trans women and you
know different different all walks of
life so it's just I don't know it's it's
really changed the way that the the
queer community has looked at itself and
I think they're very positive you know
RuPaul got so much [ __ ] for the line IB
people got mad at RuPaul for saying like
for the [ __ ] and like saying that
RuPaul would like was using Gmail or
okay the mail coming in the [ __ ] or
[ __ ] or no but there was a feat was
there wasn't there a Thea called the
[ __ ] yeah they had a section like
girl you got shemail which means like
that was like the message in the show
we're all booked well like instead of
email it yes puns like but he got [ __ ]
for it was like pretty ladies at Ray's
friend he's a it broke a lot of barriers
in them people get pissed off at him I'm
babbling yeah sorry I push back that's a
really delicate statement I fell into
that one I understand too you know yeah
you know I don't know you but I'm just
based on some of your responses and I
hope you don't take offense to this and
some of the stories is listening to you
tell unlike YouTube and stuff like that
you strike me as a person that's quick
to anger and and does not avoid comfort
like you talk okay all right I do get
angry easily and the most annoying part
about it is like people oh because I'm a
redhead right away or they're like bill
burr that's like he said what is it
taking bill burrs
like taking a I'm just an angry person
yeah I just get mad at stuff some are
you're Irish yeah and Italian Oh Santino
yeah yeah yeah because when I mean I
when I just mentioned money - Schultz I
was talking to Schultz and you're right
they don't get any [ __ ] money here
yeah there it is that's all I'm thinking
about the whole festival my hotel my
family I'm [ __ ] money I'm not gonna
eat any money am I gonna do but no I
like I just say I just kind of have not
a negative disposition but I just have I
am I have an attitude about everything
my dad was a drug addict he wasn't
around you know we want to get into it
you guys want to buckle in for this
let's do it let's do think that that's
why you found success people don't want
to hear comments go up on stage and say
I had a lovely dinner last night
yeah angry Friday middle ground we could
get - I don't to mention his name but
I'm doing I've been working on a project
with somebody who I went out to dinner
with who's very successful and I wish I
wish I would've been a more [ __ ] this
guy was just saying to me how he was
like we were just talking about our
lives and where we're from because we
don't really know each other and we're
gonna and he was basically just like
everything that's I've ever wanted has
happened for me and I was like really
he's like yeah I've really not had a lot
of struggle my family life is great like
and it made me so unknown I was so angry
yeah because I was like how the most
people that have that situation don't
really even want to get in the business
if everything is perfect you wouldn't
get into this you know I mean like for
you you're sitting there like comedy is
doing pretty well for you I would say
you get quite a name for yourself yeah
your podcast is doing really well you're
in great movies you're great TV series
yeah I don't understand why you wouldn't
say everything I've ever wanted for
myself I've gotten b-cup uh I don't know
because I think because [ __ ] them right
yeah [ __ ] yeah I get don't you
inherently always want more I mean like
look at the second look at your success
Jimmy like oh your success like don't
you always still want to really pass
that away from me quickly huh just kind
of like you like you say it's got a life
figured out girl
sure wait a Montreal go back come on up
you don't but you don't you always think
like it's a fear that first of all
whenever you get what you think you want
it to be like oh there's so much more
stuff but it's also you're afraid of
like if I'm not unhappy or angry do I
lose my motive it's a scary thing like
what am I the same person if I don't
feel this way anymore there's a boxer
named Howard Hopkins remember yeah yeah
let's fight didn't go he always had to
have the villain like he also had always
had to be the VIP lady yeah he'll in
order to like motivate himself for the
fights and then it was a weird time in
his career where he got so popular that
people start to like him and he didn't
understand how to play that role like he
played the role of stomping on the flag
of the guy who was fighting and yeah
ventually you either I guess use it as
motivation your all time or maybe you
can get to like a namaste Sam level
where it's right everything's like this
guy really when I'm not joking around
had life figured out then why tell me
why I mean I hair you just it's not
figured out at least horribly disfigured
but it's kind of like it's kind of like
you know I I don't know if it may be
Chapelle said it or someone who's saying
so saying how like some of the worst
things that can happen to a comic is
like a lot of success and money and and
I don't know if that's necessarily true
but I know what they're saying you don't
I mean like I know the idea that it's
like the more things that do come your
way and when life gets kind of good and
comfortable you can you can kind of [ __ ]
this thing up because like the more
comfortable you get the more you're like
look I start taking things for granted
and you kind of just like you get look I
just we just got a house and it was a
huge accomplishment to [ __ ] get I was
like wow I feel really good but there's
moments when I'm like I can't think
about it like that
I can't be like comfy in my backyard
being like yeah comedy bought me a house
cuz then you get to a point of like to
in your own it has to be how the [ __ ] am
I gonna pay this mortgage exactly yeah
it feels better than I was not so much
about like I don't know if it's like
about always staying angry because I
think a lot of comics will like keep
themselves in a position to like feel
like they're going up hill because that
gives them
motivations right talk about you get too
much then you feel like you're at the
top of the hill and you're gonna I feel
like the motivation has to come from
some other like some some form of
needing to express yourself and maybe
you just do that easy with anger yeah I
mean I'm not always that you know me I'm
not always angry I don't find no angry
you don't think it's an angry person no
I don't I don't think he's an angry
person but maybe we've just always kind
of when we've hung out it's always been
pretty relaxing yeah but I do have I did
there is a thing that snapped I mean
dude in the [ __ ] Airport I just have
I have I have no patient I'm very i bad
patients I sure about that and I'm in
the airport in a long line to get
through the [ __ ] customs and finesse
Mitchell is like on the other end of the
customs he can see me getting annoyed
from 150 yards away is he sympathetic to
you he just knows me enough to know he
enjoying it he just goes Santino kicked
out this Airport he could tell I'm doing
like like the old man like where's the
line start you know like that and I just
think like it's a part of my it's just a
part of my fabric of who I am it's also
my whole family's like that like
everyone gets annoyed at everything
where were you raised from Chicago I'm
from Chicago are you yeah Arlington
Heights my grandfather worked at the
track hood I grew up next to the track
did you really have people do you guys
never see the Sears Tower generate
gambling addict who worked at the
ditalion yes he worked at the track and
his paycheck went back to the track two
houses you dad was always a bunch of old
wopsle yeah screaming horses I never
knew my grandfather was like involved
with you know the mob is a cheap word I
don't know it with people
my grandma's family was yeah I didn't
know until I got older because then all
his friends were like Joe the Hat was
his best friend and I was like Joe the
hats not a legitimate [ __ ] human
being that's but he gambled away two
houses two houses yeah I lost twice lost
two to two houses
oh my women put up with back then like
yeah yeah yeah - thank you son of a
[ __ ] I've got five kids at home we're
gonna be fine don't worry
but he but and he's alive and my grandma
[ __ ] dead but he just said he lived
through he live oh [ __ ] yeah yeah he'll
never stop no no no they go to the boat
you know they go to the boat yes in
Chicago in in in Chicago you got to go
to the riverboat Nikki try town yeah
you're not supposed to game no no no
have a little deep dish that's like I do
I do too but I think pub news better
were you like pub pizza like like
Pequod's like flat square you've always
liked when people say Chicagoland yeah I
love that's a cool name for visiting the
Chicagoland area the Drudge Report
always does that Chicagoland but have
you ever ended up Santino like in a
scenario where like your patients you
you just you you've lost your patients
you're now in an argument with somebody
and you realize once you're in the
argument oh no I'm the [ __ ] here I
got I can't get out of oh I got yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay I ran I'm going I'm
walking I'm walking down the street with
my [ __ ] wife and I'm and I rent I run
into a girl that I did a show with and I
was like we were so excited I was so
excited to see her she gets out of her
car and this guy he's trying to parallel
park in front of her and he's getting
like super close he's I can tell he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's doing so
I'm kind of like doing one of these like
looking at him like a flown out you know
he's like coming up on the curb then he
backs up any smashes into her car mm-hmm
and it's not bad it's just like a it's a
bump but he gets out and I lose it and I
decide I'm gonna be the [ __ ] hero and
I'm like you hit a [ __ ] car and I'm
showing off a little bit and I'm
thinking I'm like mr. tough guy and in
the middle of yelling at this guy I
realized like I'm I'm making I'm telling
him I'm give her money
give her some [ __ ] money and this
poor like 65 year old man is like taking
money out of a school yeah yeah so I
made him give her money
you guys have car insurance yeah it's a
[ __ ] I like realize in the middle put
myself in his position handing her money
I mean dude I'm yelling at this guy and
he's literally even hundreds of dollars
and she's crying and yet so you think
that when no one handled that well
my wife walked away she was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] she just left and me and this
girl and she think it's okay I'm like
it's not okay you [ __ ] hit her car
and he's like he said what do you want
me to do him I give her money
[ __ ] and he's pulling out money
in the middle of it I can see from
10,000 feet someone's like that guy's a
bad guy somebody's got to pull you aside
you know you're not angry about the car
yeah you understand right now you're not
angry about the car the therapist he
just hugs me it's okay did you think
that's a comics thing but don't you
think that comics share like you'll be
like if I'm with friends or like on a
date or something I am so looking at
everyone around me and like anger like
why isn't she wearing makeup what are
they doing what the hell is got you know
and like fire you're just concentrating
on what's happening everybody I think
that's a common thing that comics shares
we're constantly looking around it's
like look at that [ __ ] it is a
comics thing too is also yelling at an
old man like if that guy was Blake
Griffin you probably are you okay do you
want to hit her car again yeah but
living in the moment is a hard thing for
comics to do I think that's so funny to
people who live in the moment live in
the moment and it's one of the hardest
things that's why we like the stage
because we're forced to live in the
moment
look at that happen Jules me we're like
when I'm like really stressed about [ __ ]
I can't wait to be on stage saying
because I know like for that time that's
the only thing I can think about takes
all right do you approach it like okay
put my problems behind me and go up on
stage do my act or are you just like I'm
in a bad mood I'm gonna be in a bad mood
I'm gonna go up there and prowl that
stage like a panther you know what the
most infuriating thing I've ever seen is
like he says prowl the stage like a
panther I saw Jim do a New Year's Eve
show and it wasn't really part of his
tour and he had already filmed the
special so he didn't really like care
like he was doing a good show but he
didn't care and he actually on stage
goes you know sometimes I like to get up
here and just prowl like a panther and
he actually started throwing the
microphone from hand to hand and
prowling like a panther like you were in
cats yes yes and it was in I should
enjoy himself so much in a theatre
you really did enjoy that but certainly
yes what well do you like it like to
answer your question little bit like
sometimes there's days where like if I'm
gonna fight with somebody or you know
like something's going on and [ __ ]
like it's it's it's hard to not take it
to the stage but also there is that
switch that you just have to put on that
[ __ ] that thing and it goes away but
the moment I walk off onstage
walk up say it like comes back comes
right back yeah it's so [ __ ] you have
bits are like they require certain
energy yeah no I mean like yeah like
this bit is maybe I'm more angry this
bit a more like goofy with it but then
if you're angry and you try to be goofy
a bit you just sound like a piece of
[ __ ] garbage yeah why are you so
pissed off at like so yeah it seemed
like a mean guy I don't know about about
needing like the villain or like needing
something to overcome and why I think
when people get successful they they end
up like killing themselves they get so
sad is like sometimes you get everything
you wanted and then you realize that
wasn't enough mmm right this is it
yeah that's why people kill it like all
these like rockers like they're like
their whole lives like I'm gonna be
happy once I'm touring around the world
and I'm selling out stadiums and then
they do it and they're still miserable
and they're like oh [ __ ] it's me I might
as well kill me well you also nothing
else to put off like cuz you're like all
right I got to do this but first and
then once thought there's no more but
first feel I got [ __ ] now yeah I'm not
gonna kill myself until I achieve these
goals and then you achieve these goals
and you're like well I guess this is
what I've always said I'm too selfish to
kill myself like I really have like I'd
want to know I just want to know what's
going what's next you want to see the
response yeah yeah so bad yeah way too
everybody's just heartbroken to say
about me yeah that's always I always
think like you're like I'll just going
on a coma instead I just wanna stick
around and watch the janitor have to
clean it up
[Laughter]
get your moksha how quick before sam
takes her name off the shelf sitting
there with an exacto knife on these
plastic banners he'd be doing while he
was on the phone really how did it
electrical tapes I don't have to
actually scratch anything discovered Jim
and Sam were here he'd want us to
continue the next and I really wouldn't
Sam so I feel like you had you have it
all figured out I don't know about that
I feel you have it all figured out and
sometimes we have these conversations
you know off-air sure but you have an
amazing disposition for this business
right you seem like a pretty
happy-go-lucky guy you seem to have
goals but you don't seem to be so
obsessed to the point of misery into and
trying to like obtain them and [ __ ] just
keeps working out for you it's weird to
listen to someone who's obviously never
met Sam Robb well I mean a lot of that's
been beaten out of me too you know what
I mean
no like the the sort of like I have to
do this I'm gonna do it's like now it's
not let's just just keep following the
course let's just keep following the
course and it's gonna work out but what
is the course I think that's the hardest
part for most people right like that's
probably the most oftenly ask question
to me you know just to work just keep
doing the work it's all I ever think
about it's all I do just keep doing the
work keep getting on stage more and more
keep doing more of these shows keep is
you're gonna watch a podcast launch a
podcast but just keep doing the work and
I mean it's not like no consistency
Swardson see and make the work good and
don't sit there and go like you know if
I just make the work good eventually
it'll pay off just yeah just do it for
the sake of the work yeah and if it
doesn't work out at least the work was
good well it's hard in this industry
because people can drive themselves
crazy it's very competitive and you look
always looking at your shoulder well
they've got this they've got that what
am I gonna do how am I gonna afford rent
how am I
you know there's so much it's hard to
just keep staying the course it's also
like there's a tremendous like I've
gotten to this place in life where it
takes two seconds for me to look at
somebody go oh [ __ ] him just looking at
people [ __ ] off of everything okay I
mean yeah and that makes you go through
your day a little bit easier yeah it
doesn't either [ __ ] off
yes bacon yeah or they or it's all fake
it's all it's all it's all smoke and
mirrors I mean I also grew up watching
wrestling so the idea of everything
being fake you love it it's fine yeah
it's not even like oh this is better
it's just like it's it's accepted doing
don't you think that a part of that
staying the course is like knowing
you're lame though I think that's the
most like that yeah just do we know
you're good at things lane yeah what
you're good at you see guys that like
there's a guy there's a comic that you
may not know but he Susan Boyle yes but
he he was talking to me a long time ago
who's like how can I get it how come I
can't get in the Comedy Store and I said
well I don't think it's your scene like
I don't think it's not his brand of
humor right that's gonna fit in that
thing and he was so concerned about it
and I said dude you're so good at this
thing that you do and and he was doing
like churches like he was doing [ __ ]
churches in the Midwest joel/john no
this kitchens massive dude yeah so this
is crazy this is like 10 years ago and
he was talking to be he's like I just
want to get in so bad how do you how do
I get in there that it uh I know that
you just focus on this thing that you're
doing you're so [ __ ] good at that
right and look at him now dude he sells
out her yeah massive theater what did
you do he's religious he's very good a
religious he clean but he does he does
for it's not like he's like you won't
think he's when you're like oh no you
wouldn't assume that he is like a
Christian comic that's exactly right but
that is a scene first what he does a
good job of like kind of merging these
worlds of of still being true to his
humor yeah if we're a Christian audience
and it just happens to be clean do you
know right yeah but it's so [ __ ] he's so
[ __ ] successful I mean you know so
you're right you've seen like and
and I keep you know he hit me a couple
of months ago and he was ok I want you
to come be with me at The Wiltern ight
cuz it's like a big deal and he sold out
the [ __ ] two shows at The Wiltern in
Los Angeles was massive yeah and if I
open for him yeah I don't think I would
but he stayed in his [ __ ] Lane right
and I thought that was so I was so
impressed by that because I was given
the [ __ ] advice I was like dude
you're so good at this stay in this Lane
and he did and now you know I think
that's the way to do it only people that
will be upset at not getting something
that they don't even want yeah yes oh
yes oh yes and it's true because it was
so competitive instead of just figuring
out exactly what the [ __ ] we want to do
and then going after that like right
like even with the internet [ __ ] that I
was doing like I thought I want to eat
feel special or Netflix special my whole
life right when people started watching
my clips at that level I was like oh no
I just wanted to do comedy
you just want eyes in here I don't give
a [ __ ] weird right nothing to me where
it is
yeah there's also like like if I get a
hint of not being appreciated with
something like you guys were talking
about your auditions and stuff yeah I'm
so quick to jerk off then what do you
mean what do you mean like if somebody's
like like you know staying in your lane
like there there's no part of me anymore
that goes like oh I just want to get
into this thing yeah no but there is
there's a moment of like weird jealousy
even though you're right even though you
know you don't want it like that like
like when a festival happens it's like a
cluster fest or something like that and
like I don't want to go to that thing
but I do know that like there's a piece
of you that goes right over there I want
to be invited yeah well no right yeah
yeah it's the ugly chick that like won't
give you any play yeah you're just like
you should want to [ __ ] me you [ __ ] me
yeah it's just it's that's a car that's
a comics disposition is a comic you know
a lot of times if something doesn't work
out make sure you're always working on
something you know yes have some other
idea don't just put all your eggs in one
basket I think that's the hard thing to
is people just like you said you're like
this audition yeah if I get this show
you'd even want the show gonna be a bad
show and then you suddenly realize all
do it myself I'm great is it when they
show you auditions where it gets
canceled there's nothing better and
don't get it and it goes off the air
then I efficient for King of Queens and
I'm telling a callback to it and didn't
get it I love that show end up do you
I've done I've done shows where I thank
God it didn't [ __ ] work out I had I
had a show that I was gonna do called
How I Met Your father oh no was this
spin-off for How I Met Your Mother now
you don't need so what no it was it was
crazy they were they they pretty much
just like offered it to me I was going
to be gay on the show I was gonna be her
gay brother fun with another which I've
been studying for that role my whole
life you know my husband was gay but I
but a day I remember I remember going to
it and being really uncomfortable
because they were also that like the
amount of hubris was like where this
jockstrap yeah yeah well I to peg him it
was they but they were like oh you they
were like we're going to New York we're
gonna move to New York just wait this
show is gonna [ __ ] and I went home and I
was like [ __ ] I don't want to be a part
of this show and I was like wishing and
hoping and praying that didn't go cuz I
hated every second how was the script
and the dialogue was our [ __ ] it was so
[ __ ] bad cuz they gave him so much
money those two dudes that created the
original they gave them so much [ __ ]
money to just do this for fun that it
was like nobody gave a [ __ ] it was
almost like they're not doing it for an
audience anymore funny things get
written like you're like God who the
[ __ ] taught this was funny no I I was I
was asked I had a sound like an NDA and
everything there's like couples like
four years ago and they're like we're
redoing queer I and we want you to come
on dish and we think you'd be great for
this role and I was just like no and I
think it's a great show and I love those
guys but I know I'm so mean and I don't
care about other people that I don't
want to walk into some dumpy wives house
and my husband can't put his pants on
right and then I have to like prance
around and be like we'll fix it like I
just don't care what do you think do
they know you a little bit then the guys
the guys on the show are really great
and they did a really great job redoing
I nobody annoys you nobody on that show
and I was you know I'm really not
annoyed by
well I really I think they're great I
think you think that's true though
anytime I think there's one of them that
annoys me there's somebody annoys him
yeah boys usually pretty honest fashion
sometimes I feel like some of those guys
put it on so much I'm like all right I
don't I think that's also can be
straight people's perception is they
just don't understand that gay men can
actually behave that hey man I don't
have a problem with that just don't put
it in my face
yeah dear me like my friend like when
I'm hang it like Mike I got a crew in
New York and most of them are
professional drag queens and when we're
just alone like playing like super smash
brothers and stuff like my firm Patti it
literally it's you know I'm like
sometimes I watch I'm like oh it's
people probably think he's putting on an
act was just the way it's a way yes you
know Naomi smalls
yeah Naomi smalls oh my god Naomi yeah
good friends yes you know her yeah yeah
yeah or him yes she came Davis is his
name he came to when I did Stephen
Colbert he was backstage that's the
fashion song no yes I have you guys seen
in your office's Instagram I need to
link up we really if you don't follow
it's only on his story fashion but he
died it's so great it's okay
it's how he promotes the t-shirts that
he's got on sale at his shows he just
puts on this has to know by now he's
wearing like one of his shirts and
they're all kind of like parodies of
like brand name stuff like off-white or
whatever it is and the song is playing
and Andrew and his video guy are just
doing a perfectly choreographed walk and
dance with claps to this fashion song
and I've become if you start watching
and you should once you start watching
it you'll become so obsessed to the
point where when Schulz puts out an
Instagram story and it's not a fashion
thing I'm like I would love to do we get
Naomi in one oh my god crazy
yeah I've never seen one I follow great
I'll show you check the stories when he
posts I'll show you I'll show you when
we're all okay yeah it's just a fun
random thing we always have some kind of
random flip at the end like I did indoor
skydiving and
like we went to a room don't be don't be
[ __ ] humble he's he did one of those
indoor skydive [ __ ] machines and it
looked like a choreograph that wasn't me
dude it blew my mind - I could I wasn't
you so he does so bro it blew my [ __ ] I
just text an ally oh this you guys know
that's the indoor skydiving machine
bunker was so it wasn't you so what we
did knock sucker I did it but then we
had a sessional guy he does this thing
where the song is playing and like it's
just like a pan of his face like it
looks like there's like 19 takes of this
like it's perfect the cameras panning
around the suits being zipped up Schultz
is just making direct eye contact with
the camera he's walking with the fashion
song and then somewhere in there and I
didn't know this until he told me
there's a cut that I didn't notice I
didn't know because once he gets in to
the Machine he starts like doing
choreographed backflips and dancing and
stuff inside the indoor skydiving
machine and I'm like this [ __ ]
must have learned how to indoor skydive
yeah come to find out it's all [ __ ]
and if you look at it he's not even
wearing the same color shoes put the
microphone so you can hear the song you
know what sorry that you really that
just let me down so much isn't it like
yeah that really it's great and we go to
the podcast yeah one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app